el anuncio de la llegada de la cantante
Taylor Swift a Argentina generó una
importante revuelo a pesar de que los
tickets comunes más baratos superan los
30 mil pesos unos 130 dólares misma
cifra que vale la canasta básica
alimentaria y volvió a poner en
discusión la gravedad de la crisis
económica al respecto la portavoz
presidencial Gabriela tuvo un
controvertido comentario en Twitter días
atrás la gente no llega a fin de mes
pero se patina la guita en restaurantes
y recitales todos boludos las dos fechas
que la estadounidense harán el estadio
de River Plate se suman antecedentes
como los 10 recitales de Coldplay en
2022 o la gran cantidad de viajes que
hubo para el mundial de fútbol de Qatar
analistas explican este fenómeno de una
manera la distribución de la riqueza es
cada vez más despareja en Argentina
El Avance de la desigualdad provoca que
haya un grupo más reducido de la
población que tiene acceso a cada vez
más niveles de ingreso Y eso es lo que
permite la aparición de estos fenómenos
la crisis económica Argentina continúa
profundizándose según los datos del
indec en abril la canasta básica de
alimentos subió un 7,3% llegando a
94.148 pesos para una familia
tradicional de cuatro personas además la
pobreza ronda el 40% y la inflación
interanual llegó al 108,8% en este
contexto la situación invita a
ciudadanos de otros países aprovechar la
oportunidad y Ver artistas
internacionales a un coste más bajo